mal den schon etwas älter jetzt bin ich
echt ein sitz geriet etwas klappt jetzt
bekommen beim ein video ja was geht ab
heute habe ich wirklich mal wieder was
krasses war also ich weiss ich einige
von euch kann sich wahrscheinlich doch
anders wie du erinnern wo ich halt so
gesagt hat so jo ich rauche und habe
dann halt so geguckt was meine zuschauer
oder irgendwelche menschen dazu sagen
also ich habe damals ich kann einfach
mal kurzen ausschnitt einbinden hat
dieser snap jetzt einfach 94 screenshots
das muss man sich mal vorstellen
490 und spaß und draußen ich habe halt
damals einfach ein snap gepostet mit
einer zigarette und das ist wirklich
durch die decke gegangen ist video war
wirklich alle wissen wollten die leute
darauf reagieren wenn ein youtuber
braucht und heute habe ich mir gedacht
komm machst du das gleiche doch einfach
nochmal in dem du so sah ich mal dich so
darstellt als würdest du okay das kommt
jetzt folgt als würde ich so durch meine
abonnenten sage ich mal oder diesen
ganzen druck immer neue gute videos zu
bringen so ein bisschen heißt
alkoholabhängig werden oder einfach
jetzt alkohol zu trinken und ich habe
mir da einen guten alten freund von mir
besorgt und zwar diese flasche wein ist
kein guter alter freund von mir jetzt
eine ganz normale bacardi flasche für
die die es nicht wissen bacardi ist eine
alkohol flasche und hier ist jetzt
wasser drin kann ich euch auch kurz
zeigen dass er wirklich was da drin ist
nein spaß wirklich was sage ich da ist
was dann würde ich mir ist wirklich was
da drin so und hier ist mein handy mit
snapshot drauf ich weiß eigentlich gar
nicht was ist los mit snapshot so
snapshot ist die einzige plattform wo
ich denke warum sind dort ist nicht mehr
so viele wie früher
ich mein ich poste welchen lässt das
hängt wieder coole snaps deswegen checkt
auf jeden fall meinen snapshot ab es
kann auch sein dass snapshot die haben
ja auch irgendwas verändert auf jeden
fall sehen meine story nicht mehr so
viele wie früher was jetzt an sich kein
ding ist aber ich bin es schade weil
switches es gab deswegen folgt mir auf
jeden fall besser chat wenn es nicht tut
ja also ich hab ein snapshot öffentlich
gestellt und wir fangen jetzt einfach
mal irgendwas mit dieser flasche
anzustellen daraus zu trinken sie in ein
anderes so wisst ihr das halt leute
denken so jo der trink jetzt alkohol und
das voll schlecht drauf und wir checken
dann einfach mal die reaktion von den
leuten ab ich bin sehr gespannt ich
hoffe hier auch und das nämlich jetzt am
besten schnell mal mit meiner welt
bis gleich so leute ich hab immer
gedacht ich mach dazu einfach noch
irgendwie so ja so traurig
also ich meine wenn man es jetzt schon
macht dann kann man natürlich auch
übertreiben achtung
[Musik]
das ist gut
leute ich komme auf den ganzen druck
nicht mehr klar
jeden tag ein video zu machen dass euch
gefällt die macht das am besten genau
ich mach erst mal einfach nur ein bild
von der flasche
ok als nächstes muss ich kurz was auch
immer man ich lebe ich schon selber also
mehrmals hier dieses diesen snap ich
schreibe dazu jetzt einfach mal jeden
tag dieser stress
das hat sie einfach so krass gut an
einfach daneben geschüttet das ist jetzt
auch in einer story also meine story
sieht jetzt so aus
[Musik]
ok ich finde das habe ich schon mal gut
gemacht jetzt würde ich sagen wir warten
erstmal ab was sich so ergibt und was
ich für nachrichten bekomme ich bin
wirklich sehr gespannt bis gleich ich
hasse diese bank na ja ich setze jetzt
auf jeden fall wieder hier was ich
erstmal noch sagen muss bevor wir jetzt
anfangen diese ganzen nachrichten zu
öffnen also ich krieg täglich pro minute
20 snaps ungelogen wollte ich noch
schnell sagen
also ich will mit diesem video jetzt
wirklich keinen dazu auffordern wenn es
euch mal nicht so gut geht dass ihr dann
alkohol trinkt oder so das ist total
gestört dann denkt einfach an was
positives oder guckt alle meine videos
genau und ich kriege auch greift schon
whatsapp nachrichten also keine ahnung
du hast auch du hast du eine
vorbildfunktion unsere deswegen nur ein
experiment vielleicht ist ja schon mal
gemacht also ki.ka selección alles cool
okay jetzt bin ich vollauf eures netz
gespannt so viel was los mit dir willst
reden
ich warte jetzt einfach mal las man
reden waren besser wat für haare was
geht
hey leute ist das euch heiße gehalt alex
seine haare sind toll und ich wollte dir
noch sagen dass ich einfach ein mega fan
bin und ich liebe du bist einfach so
cool und voll süß und dass du einfach
jetzt alkohol trinke zu viel stress hast
ist mir egal es so ernst alki übertreibt
er jetzt bin ich echt einsetzt ich
dachte jetzt kommt voll die krassen
sachen hey guckt euch das mal an ich
habe jetzt bestimmt fünfzehn snaps
geöffnet und einer davon hat gesagt hey
das ist nicht cool und der rest sagt
jörg i
übertreibt man nicht so ich mache mir
gerade echt sorgen um euch ok
sprachnachricht von heiko leute das muss
die einstellung sein ich komm grad nicht
drauf cloud hoch
vorweg alter als ob du das jetzt pur
trinkst du schickst du dass bilder von
und macht einfach so kuckuck macht leute
guckt euch das mal an ist das irgendwie
ist das normal für euch gut läuft die
uhr wir haben 16 10
die jugend geht kaputt die jugend geld
wir warten jetzt einfach kurz ab ich
melde mich länger macht okay leute ich
habe jetzt noch mal eine halbe stunde
abgewartet und mal gucken was die leute
mir jetzt schicke deine videos euch
gerne kannst du mir helfen
ich will das mit meinen haaren machen
mag kinder schokolade und das sich
gerade alkohol trinkt ist ihr egal oder
was echt dreh ab ja geil baby warum
deutsche was soll das was soll das was
ist denn falsch wie recht du hast bruder
warum hab ich gerade recht es ist 16 uhr
ich hab doch kein recht grad
ich stehe voll scheiße da ich dachte
borat ist knallt richtig rein alle sind
enttäuscht von mir und dann kommt so
snap zu jung
mach weiter so jo du bist der geilste
wie geht's ich mag deine haare nicht das
ist kein grund für mich noch weiter an
der jugend zu zweifeln was soll ich dazu
jetzt noch sagen das war wirklich mal
ein flop der ging nach hinten los endet
nicht auf jeden fall weiß neptun und
lass mal nach oben da wenn ihr noch
weitere experimente sehen wollt weil die
sind immer die klappen einfach immer so
gut schreibt doch einfach mal in die
kommentare
womit ich noch experimentieren so ich
bin gerade wirklich enttäuscht von euch
das kann ich ganz offen und ehrlich mal
sagen von den leuten die die mich bei
snapshot von folgen
ich bin enttäuscht na ja das war's mit
dem video ich hoffe es hat euch sehr
unterhalten dass der daumen nach oben da
und wir sind uns dann vielleicht morgen
wieder
ich muss das aber erstmal verarbeiten
vielleicht auch als freitag keine ahnung
haben
schaut mal bei instagram vorbei würde
mich sehr freuen